local leaders coming together tonight to  discuss ways nevada can make the process  of home  ownership more fair tonight's event was  put on by the coalition to make homes  possible  the goal here is to empower up to 25  thousand families with  resources including down payment  assistance and other real estate  services  they acknowledge the progress made over  the years but says more needs to be done  our country has made progress towards  addressing the housing discrimination  that exists throughout our country  however  discrimination still remains a reality  for  far too many americans tonight's panel  highlighted black men and women in the  mortgage and lending industry their hope  is to inspire  others to get involved to help close the  gap together